well my name is Jeff Friedman I'm a
professor at the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute at Rockefeller University and
I'm pleased to be part of the IEEE
biology series today I'm going to tell
you about our research into the causes
of obesity and the discovery of the
hormone leptin the clinical problem our
science addresses is obesity and at some
level we'd like to understand why it is
some individuals have the appearance of
the child on the left and other people
have the appearance of the child on the
right if you ask the average person why
the difference most people would say
well the individual on the Left eats too
much well that would be true but it
would ignore the deeper question which
is why does the individual on the Left
eat too much and I'd like to try to
answer that question for you today now
there are several general reasons to
explain why some individuals might eat
more than others one possibility is to
suggest that the obese lack a level of
willpower that's more evident in lean
people I find that point of view is more
often favored by lean people second
possibility is to suggest that we live
in a modern environment that predisposes
to obesity and a third possibility would
be to suggest that body weight is
controlled by biological factors and
genes the interest of time I'm not going
to discuss the relative contributions of
willpower and environment but tell you
in fact that there's substantial
evidence that genes play a dominant role
to control body weight there are a
number of ways to assess the genetic
contributions to a particular trait the
standard way to do so is to
systematically compare twin pairs
identical twins share all of their genes
fraternal twins only share half their
genes
so if identical twins are more alike for
a particular trait than non identical
twins we can calculate the genetic
contribution to that trait if you do
this for obesity what you find is that
obesity is as or more hereditable than
any trait that gets that's yet been
studied with the exception of height in
fact obesity is more hereditable than
many traits that we commonly consider
have a genetic basis including
schizophrenia diabetes hypertension
alcoholism and heart disease
in fact we can calculate based on this
about that about seventy to eighty
percent of the variation in body weight
can be ascribed to genetic factors now
to show you the potency of these genetic
factors to control weight I would like
to tell you about a case report this is
the child whose image I began by showing
you the child was of normal weight at
birth but began to develop morbid
obesity very early in life
his parents reported intense hyperphagia
or an intense increased appetite to the
point where they even padlocked the
refrigerator to keep the child from
getting free access to food despite this
to cut the child kept getting fatter and
at the age of four he weighed 90 pounds
and was already pre-diabetic now this
child had a similarly affected
eight-year-old cousin who weighed over
200 pounds
both these children came from an inbred
family and oftentimes when you see in an
extreme phenotype in an inbred family in
this case as a result of a first cousin
marriage it's a result of a genetic
alteration so Steve O'Reilly and
colleagues suggested that perhaps this
child was obese as a result of a
mutation in a particular gene and they
hypothesized that this child might be
missing a hormone leptin that was first
identified by my laboratory leptin is a
hormone made by fat tissue that's
secreted into the blood where it
circulates ultimately acting on the
brain to regulate food intake in the
absence of leptin animals eat more and
so a rally suggests that perhaps this
child was missing the hormone leptin
they tested and indeed the child was
missing leptin so they decided to now
take leptin that was made in the
laboratory and give it back to this
child and what you can see is that the
child from between the ages of 4 & 6
lost a substantial amount of weight
despite getting taller in addition the
child ate less before the first leptin
injection he ate 2000 calories at a
single meal after a few left and
injections the child now ate 180
calories at the same meal which is the
appropriate number of calories for a
child of that age and size in this case
the child was obese because of a defect
in the hormone leptin without leptin no
signal is ever generated that there
- quit fat stores this is a stimulus to
eat more and this child kept eating kept
getting fatter without ever making the
signal that shut the system off and now
here's a picture of the child at the age
of 8 it's the same child I began by
showing you a picture of so this child
was obese not as a result of a lack of
willpower or a toxic environment this
child was obese because a lack of a lack
of the hormone leptin studies of this
child and other individuals has now
suggested that body weight is regulated
by a hormonal loop of which leptin is an
important component at our stable weight
food intake equals energy expenditure
and we make a particular amount of
leptin now imagine if that mass falls
after a diet leptin level would fall a
low leptin level will be provide a
stimulus to eat more much is the same as
the case in the untreated leptin
deficient child and you'll now an
individual have a potent stimulus to
their appetite until such time as their
fat mass and leptin level returns to the
starting point conversely if you overeat
for a period of time a bit binge of
eating fat mass goes up and leptin level
goes up with it
this will suppress appetite again until
such time as fat mass and leptin level
return to the starting point
so because leptin is made in proportion
to fat mass it provides a signal that
can then control food and take in the
response to weight loss or weight gain
and what this system does in a sense is
set up a biological response that
resists weight change in either
direction if you lose fat mass leptin
level falls and it's a stimulus to gain
weight if you gain fat mass leptin level
rises and that suppresses appetite and
by this mechanism body weight can be
maintained within a relatively narrow
range now if you hear all of this and
find that there was an undiscovered
hormone circulating in the in the blood
of animals and humans it seems rather
mysterious to consider how this hormone
was identified so I'd like to now tell
you about how I became interested in
this hormone and how it was discovered
my interest in this area began with an
interest in behavior how molecules
control behavior and my first interest
centered on a
another hormone that said to regulate
appetite CCK cholecystokinin is a
hormone made by an endocrine cells in
your intestine in response to food when
food is present inside your gut CCK is
secreted into the blood and it
stimulates the contraction of your
gallbladder and the secretion of enzymes
by your pancreas that aid in digestion
and this was the situation in 1968 prior
to the work of Smith and Gibbs who also
showed that CCK can suppress appetite
they suggested in fact that this at this
intestinal hormone when it secreted not
only helps you a digestion but also
circulates in the blood and acts on the
brain to shut off a meal made perfect
sense excitement in this area was
amplified when a few years later C CK
was also found in the brain by a group
led by Graham da Cray this then
suggested that perhaps appetite and body
weight are regulated by a comp by a
hormone that is expressed in both the
gut and the brain and that the levels of
perla Freesat peripherally synthesized
in brain synthesize C CK might control
food intake and body weight and this was
referred to at the time as the gut brain
axis interest in this area was amplified
even further in 1979 when Strauss niala
reported that the levels of C CK were
reduced in the brains of a strange
genetically obese strain of mouse known
as the OB mouse the OB Mouse is obese as
a result of a defect in a single gene
and yellow and strauss suggested that
that defective gene might be C CK this
endogenous appetite suppressant with a
lower level of the endogenous appetite
suppressant the animals might eat more
well this is a picture of the OB mouse
it's the the animal on the far right is
an OB Mouse and the animal
here a second to the firm from the right
is a lean litter made of that animal the
only defect between the OB mouse and his
sibling littermate is a defect in a
single gene that single genetic defect
leads the OB animal to eat more move
around less ultimately weighing three
times as much and having five times as
much fat as the sibling littermate and
as I mentioned yellow suggested that
perhaps this animal overrate because it
was missing CCK this endogenous appetite
suppressant the only problem with this
idea is that it very well might be wrong
and this had to do with the fact that a
person I was working with at the time
Bruce Schneider published the
contemporaneous report showing that the
levels of CCK in brain were no different
in OB mice versus their lean littermates
and so we and others wondered whether or
not CCK was the defective gene in the OB
animals well one of the first things we
did at the time was to clone the CCK
gene and the idea was to clone the CCK
gene and see where on the chromosome it
mapped whether it mapped near the
location of the OB gene we quickly found
that C CK mapped to the distal end of
chromosome 9 this is a map of chromosome
9 with a variety of genes that map there
the only problem was that the OB gene
did map to chromosome 9 in map to
chromosome 6 so these data excluded the
possibility that C CK was the OB gene
and raised the question as to well if
it's not C CK what is it in the 1980s
when we did this work a new technology
was emerging that allowed one to
identify defective genes not based on a
knowledge of their function but simply
based on a detailed knowledge of the
chromosomal location of that gene this
methodology was known as positional
cloning and we set out then to identify
the OB gene using positional cloning
this required identifying genes in the
region of the chromosome where OB was
known to map and one day on a Friday we
found a gene in the region of OB that
was expressed only in fat tissue this is
a northern blot it's away at the time of
measuring RNA levels and only fat tissue
had an RNA for this gene which we knew
map near the OB gene the next step was
to ask is this gene defective in strains
of mice that are genetically obese and
indeed it was if you look here at Lane 2
that's fat tissue from a normal Mouse
Lane 3 is fat tissue from an OB mouse of
the same strain that that strain fails
to make the OB RNA and that's why it's
bad Lane 4 is RNA from fat tissue of
different strain of mouse and lane five
is RNA from the obese animal from that
same strain in this case increased
levels of RNA are produced and that's
because the RNA produces a defective
protein the animal then makes more and
more RNA and as a means of trying to
compensate unsuccessfully because the
RNA makes a defective protein
well the demonstration that this gene
was defective in two different OB
strains of mice confirmed that we in
fact could identify the defective gene
and this was published to some fanfare
in 1994 with this image of an obese
Mouse out weighing two of its sibling
littermates shortly after identifying
the OB gene subsequent studies revealed
in fact that the defective gene encoded
this hormone leptin it's the hormone
made by fat tissue that regulates
appetite by acting by on brain centers
one of the key experiments was done with
collaborators Jeff Hollis Kate and gaggi
wall and Steven burly together we showed
that if you inject saline into an OB
animal nothing happens they stay obese
but if you inject leptin made in the
laboratory animals normalize their
phenotype much the same as a rally and
colleagues later showed for this leptin
deficient child now leptin mutations are
quite rare there are only a few dozen
such mutations in the world which is
characteristic of hormones which are
poor targets for mutation but we now
know that perhaps 10 to 15% of morbid
obesity as a result of single gene
defects in other genes in the neural
circuit on which leptin acts and so this
has provided a great stimulus into obese
into the research into the causes of
obesity and tells us now that obesity is
very often a result of specific genetic
defects I suspect that will identify
ever more of these defects now with
advances in DNA sequencing and other new
technologies and so I think research in
this area has been greatly stimulated by
the identification of leptin and the
realization that obesity is can be the
result of genetic defects in a neural
circuit that regulates food intake and
body weight
you